نحن في ديل ريو بولاية تكساس ،
إنه يوم 16 سبتمبر ،
هذا تحت
جسر واحد
وعشرة آلاف
وخمسمائة وثلاثة
أجانب غير شرعيين
عبرت كتلة من
البشرية وتنتظر القدوم إلى
أمريكا ، سبب وجودهم هنا بسيط
منذ ثمانية
أيام  اتخذت إدارة بايدن قرارًا
سياسيًا بإلغاء
رحلات الترحيل إلى هايتي ،
لقد فعلوا ذلك
في 8 سبتمبر بعد
ثمانية أيام ،
ظهرت هذه الأرقام
في 8 سبتمبر تحت هذا الجسر
كان هناك ما بين
700 إلى ألف شخص
ولكن عندما انتشرت الكلمة
أن جو بايدن  وكمالا حريس
لم يعدوا يرحلون من جاءوا
من هايتي
فجأة كل من كان هنا
اتصل بأصدقائهم وعائلته
وارتفعت الأعداد
إلى عشرة آلاف
وخمسمائة وثلاثة
وهذا ما هو موجود هنا اليوم
هو أكثر
من قدرة دورية الحدود
على التعامل
هذه
نتيجة قرار سياسي
هذه نتيجة
لا يمكن الدفاع عنها
ما نراه
هنا هو ث
rong هذا غير إنساني وهذا
بسبب جو بايدن وكمالا
هاريس